[موسيقى]
احد ابرز علماء الذره وتكنولوجيا النانو
في العالم منير نايفه بروفيسور وعالم
فلسطينيون امريكي في الذره وابحاث النانو
ولد في العام
1945 في طولكرم وظهر شغفه بالعلم واجراء
التجارب منذ فتره الطفوله فبدا بصناعه
اجهزه الراديو وكانت هوايته المفضله
نال درجه البكالوريوس من الجامعه
الامريكيه في بيروت ثم الماجستير في
الفيزياء وحصل بعدها على منحه مقدمه من
جامعه ستانفورد الامريكيه
اهتم في الولايات المتحده بدراسه ذره
الهيدروجين باستخدام اشعه الليزر وفي هذه
الفتره حصل على درجه الدكتوراه في
الفيزياء الذريه وعلوم الليزر
عمل باحثا فيزيائيا بمعامل اجريج بجامعه
كنتاكي ثم التحق بجامعه ليحصل بعدها على
جائزه البحث التصنيعي في الولايات المتحده
نشر ما يزيد على مئه وثلاثين مقالا وبحثا
علميا وشارك مع اخرين في اعداد وتاليف
العديد من الكتب عن علوم الليزر
والكهربائيه والمغناطيسيه كما تمكن من
احداث ثوره علميه عندما نجح في تحريك
الذرات منفرده ذره ذره
واشار الكتاب السنوي الصادر عن الموسوعه
البريطانيه البريطانيه الا ان التقنيه
نايفه يمكنها زياده كفاءه اداء الالات ما
بين 100 مليون وعشره الاف مليون مره على
الطرق التقليديه
كما ذكرت صحيفه واشنطن بوست انه يؤسس لفرع
جديد في علم الكيمياء يدعى كيمياء الذره
المنفرده الذي يمهد بدوره لطفره طبيه تسهم
في علاج العديد من الامراض التي وقف العلم
عاجزا امامها سنوات طويله
راس شبكه العلماء والتكنولوجيين العرب في
الخارج كما انه عضوا في مجلس اداره
المؤسسه العربيه للعلوم والتكنولوجيا
حصل نايفه على عشرات الجوائز العلميه
المرموقه وخلد اسمه في العديد من موسوعات
العلماء والمشاهير كالموسوعه البريطانيه
الشهيره بريتانيكا
قلده الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس في
العام 2017 وسام الاستحقاق الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]